move around a little bit it's just my
style my challenge today is to actually
build on what was just said to say I
don't actually think about the term Big
Data anymore because to me big data is
absolutely useless big data is only
useful as you transform it into big
decisions so the challenge for
Australian livestock species is to do
exactly as we said before is to merge
what I consider Big Data into big
decisions and actually equip the
livestock Industries to enhance the
productivity
in the area that I work with there's
some major changes are happening in the
livestock area suffice to say that we've
probably seen in the last 12 months
changes that we wouldn't have expeced in
the last 10 years my challenge is that
producers are starting to operate more
sophisticated brand uh chains they're
starting to think about not only
supplying on weight and fact
demographics but also about how do they
fit into the brand architecture how do
they fit into the brand DNA how do they
fit into the brand ecology now all of
those three things are starting to
really differentiate producers in how
they interact with Supply chains
production driven by branded products
potenti block more in the brand so when
you actually become closer to the brand
one of the real challenges is you
actually start to move away from that
little bit of diversity that producers
actually like they like the opportunity
of diversity but with diversity comes
cost of production and with that
diversity also comes risk so being
aligned to Brand aets ups and downs
successful producers are really changing
they're starting to manage more
information they're starting equip
himself to handle this information
there's more and more sensors coming in
I'll show you some examples of that
there's this big challenge of managing
more and more animals with less labor so
corporate agriculture is moving into
this area the cultural Chang that's
happening in our uh particular space is
that we are changing 3 or 400 years of
agricultural production most farmers and
most family Farmers that You' spoken
about this morning have built themselves
on dealing with complexity around
visualization of that complexity they
walk out into the padic they observe
what their animals are doing they
observe what their Fe doing they observe
what's happening with the advance of all
of these senses you're changing that
Dynamic CU they no longer walk out into
the P to observe things they're getting
this tsunami of information presented to
them so I'll show you that in a couple
of these pictures that are coming up so
we are about to see the cultural change
of changing from visual agriculture to
what I say is its best uh driven as
information driven agriculture built
around these value chains so
transforming big data so big data
requires analysis and interpretation
into information and then interpretation
insights into decisions now the size of
those I tried to capture a little bit
there's a heap of data there's a little
bit of information and I had to put
decisions into that Circle and B
decisions in I really wanted to say the
size of decisions to be a pinpoint on
that particular side so we are investing
PS of money into agricultural data we're
not investing PS of money into
agricultural decisions and in our area
the biggest goal that we'll have
particularly in southern livestock
species is integration of what I call
the uh livestock Enterprises with the
cropping Enterprises with the pasture
Enterprises with soil Enterprises all of
those things which are the multiac areas
of mix farming businesses and there is
not one single entity that's actually
taken that role and responsibility on
MLA the company I work with they're very
happy working about livestock decisions
GDC happy working about cropping
decisions the interface between our two
areas will drive Southern Agriculture
and yet we still haven't had those
discussions so that is the role we need
to do so Emer Technologies objective
measurements changing the area and I
know Tom and Troy will talk about that
uh genetics and genomics a couple of
years ago when we first started the the
CRC we started characterizing animals
and we thought if one or two genes could
we could measured that would be
fantastic then we got something that was
measuring 100 jeans then we got
something that measured 1,000 jeans then
we got something that was measuring
50,000 je then we got something that's
measured 700,000 je now we're doing full
sequencing at 3.5 million gen and the
interesting thing full sequencing costs
now less than what it was to get one or
two jeans 5 years
ago so all of that information coming
and then when you say to the average a
sea stock producer I know there are
several in the room not only are we
going to give you this information
around F we're going to throw you back
full sequence information that full
sequence information is basically one
Gaby of information you've got 100 so we
want to transfer down 100 GB of
information down on the current download
speeds have a little heart
attack right so all of those things are
emerging that area now with this
information management how do you
actually get all this information so you
know we talk in talk in terms of of lead
Yi we're talking single figures around
percentages of L me yield what happens
if I actually gave you percentages of L
me yield in 39 muscles across the body I
also gave you the meat color of all
those muscles I gave you the pH of all
those muscles I gave you the marbling
store of all those muscles I gave you
the consumer quality scores of all those
muscles and then I said here's all this
information there's at least 39 muscles
I've given you 10 pieces of information
go ahead and breed the perfect
care producers can't even do one yet
they bit like marinas they they get to
one and they can't count past that so
we're throwing all this information
directly into their laps and we're
asking him to make much more informed
decisions and that he yet to really come
I'm a bit worried about that particular
area so we've got RI tags and they
coming things the F PS for livestock I
made a joke about 3 months ago on
another Forum I said there'll be F PS
for livestock and I noticed yesterday or
two days ago there was a major article
coming out but they've actually done
exactly that they've now got 50 P of the
livestock and they're actually thinking
they're going to get improvements in
breeding efficiency in Dairy C while
about 10% through knowledge of that
information so sometimes when you make a
joke you got to be careful about the
outcome GPS tracking we're doing all of
these things so we now know virtual
stocking rates we now are changing our
feing lines for changing our pattern of
resource utilization based on this
information we got drones and sensors
are going up in that area we got water
and and fence sensors are happening all
the time and the area that I'm most
excited about is this biolog IC tattoos
when you start to put in tattoos on
individual animals with biologically
active inks and they paress at different
frequencies and that paress tells you
about the well-being of animals now
wouldn't that be exciting you can walk
out in the padic and all the heers are
bright green so you know that they're
all
happy now or more importantly wouldn't
it be really good if you put the Drone
up and they saw all these bright green
heers and they actually reported back to
you in your office when you're sitting
inside the pool having the drink all
your he is a Happ
right now that's not too far off and
again that's going to change the face of
Agriculture and particularly
the again it's going to take the
visualization out it will change
management skills and as Phil said
earlier I'm starting to see that we're
going to change a way from Farm managers
to what I call a system as Engineers
systems Engineers actually take all of
this information and make effective
decisions they're not managing anymore
they're decision makers and again that's
a change in we havec the areas again
Chris people talk about it in her
session I encourage you to go and listen
to that later on is all these
hyperspectral cameras and new deay Dex
x-rays all this information that's going
on it's just going to throw this Sami of
of information back to livestock
producers more importantly how do they
make effective decisions about all this
of this information how do they balance
up the fact that we tell them that lean
me yield and E quality have a big
negative correlation if you want to fit
it into value based marketing to adjust
for that negative correlation the real
value is actually optimizing on those
two principles you throw a neural
network at it he's the optimal profile
for exactly the the numbers of animals
that you need in each of these sequences
and in Northern beep industry we're
doing exactly that we're starting to say
based on your genetic profile based on
the r growth you've had up to 200 days
you go on a boat and you go to a
processing
work that's the type of information
that's going to come
forward and again SPAC of technology
that little thing that's a NYX color
sensor that cost about $300 us it links
to your iPhone it does a really good job
of objective color in both beef and
sheep we think that we're able to put
all of these uh these little Nick
sensors into a range of supermarkets
basically get crowd sourcing information
back as each of the consumers picks up a
piece of meat tells whether they like
the meat color or not they come back
next time they use a little sense and
they tell us whether they like the
product or not so instead of having one
or 2,000 pieces of information some we
might have 100,000 pieces of information
consumer capability of eating Quality
Meat car on a daily
basis won't that transform how
agricultural production will go and
won't that transform how companies
integrate so it's becoming increasingly
complex so biolog the biology of of
Agriculture particularly Livestock
systems I think producers and
particularly livestock producers do a
fantastic job of doing dealing with
complexity in decision making what they
don't do well is actually handle the
complication of complexity and we are
throwing more and more complication to
that complexity we are making decisions
metric five a minute and that is going
to influence how we do those areas so it
doesn't matter where you sit in the
supply chain this increasingly complex
system of moving from complex to
complicated it's going to be a real
Challenge and to show here's the red me
language CH uh value chain this is all
the information that we've got that's
going across there does a whole hip of
information all of these traits are
coming in place the really interesting
thing is there is not one common set of
language or standards that goes across
that whole agricultural profile there's
Heats of information collected to that
and not one part of each of those
sectors talks to each other there's no
stand in the meure right way across that
Spectrum so goal of decision making
understanding these whole areas so
livestock Enterprises and my challenge
for the the livestock producers in order
to to Really grapple with big decisions
and Big Data understand resilience and
adaptability of your production system
understand where the key points are
going to be there's going to be huge
opportunity not to live productivity I
think people focus on productivity a lot
in the supply chain at least in the meat
supply chain I work in the cost of
non-compliance to livestock production
far out ways the cost of any
improvements we can make in productivity
so people producing things to a market
Endo after 6 or 700 days and getting
that wrong is far greater crost to the
industry than liting productivity by 2
or 3% and as an example with the cost of
non-compliance and a couple of Supply
chains I've worked in it's about $52 an
animal the dark cutting which is one
industry issue it's $192 a kilo it's a
$50 million issue that can be solved
just with the data that we've got
available today so there are big gains
getting rid of non so less wastage of
resources is probably the KE for
agriculture more than anything else what
are going to drive some of these things
as I said before compliance to Market
specification there's $30 to $85 ahead
value based marketing well I've gone
away from the term value based Marketing
in my STP value based pricing when you
actually have value based pricing then
you allow the value change do the market
producers shouldn't get involved in that
area business efficiency and
profitability they're all going to
leverage this information and data to
information to decisions identifying
where those key areas is going to be
quite important and from an RDC point of
view when you actually use that type of
area you will radically change
investment portfolios in R&D if you know
where the key points of transactional
efficiency are you will change where you
invest R&D dollars and at the moment we
apply a shotgun approach to that type of
area
so lots of databases uh mid or MLA we're
lucky to be the custodians of a range of
different databases so we've got n meet
stands Australia livestock data link the
national livestock recording system
where the custodians have breed plan
where the custodian uh sorry with AB
sheet genetics on Farm software Bree
societies are all involved that animal
health there's all of these databases
that com in on
board very few of them actually
integrate to together to form big
decision so in one area a little bit of
on Farm software now is linking the
national livestock recording service
with the Bureau of me meteorology to
sell a little bit of information about
when we sell and what to
Fe probably about 2% of livestock
production is starting to actively make
that
prop then we get a little bit more
complicated when we link those NIS with
me standard Australia with Loft data
link together with bre plan and Sheet
genetics and the research databases to
improve the information of eating qu and
to show you how complex our challenges
are in the area of meat standards
Australia last year we graded 3.2
million animals each of those had
measurements of intros measurements of
color measurements of verification all
those other challenges we have a
national genetics databasing breed plan
with the breed societies which is
basically the world's best at the moment
how many records out of that 3.2 million
do you think went back into the genetics
database to influence genetic decision
making that's greater than zero not by
much actually
611 so the other 2.9 million plus we
lost in terms of that contribution to
the genetics datab and and in our case
MLA manages both of them and we can't
even connect them yet so that's the
challenge we have and here's an example
of of where the real value actually lies
Tom will probably use this later on in
his talk value based marketing pilot if
we actually understood the complexity of
L that yield if we actually understood
the complexity of uh heating quality if
we can apply that the system provide
that information back to producers over
105,000 animals is $18.8 million
difference between paying on weight and
fat versus paying on real value
based
course so there's about 20 to $130 per
Animal by getting that decision right
that's a huge opportunity for the
Australian agriculture Industries to
look at so we've got a whole heap of
things there benchmarking and I won't go
through those but benchmarking gracing
systems host compliance the area that I
want to see our our Industries get much
more invoked in the BCA is about
supporting investment strategies we saw
this morning about investment in
agriculture the problem about investment
in agriculture is we are not using big
decisions to make that investment
decision for us so we can do a lot more
of those areas Health and Welfare the uh
spoke about brand DNA earlier on there's
going to be this Quantum need for
Australian agriculture to start to
underpin brands with information that
supports the brand Integrity in both
domestically domestic and international
communities and all that requires
information coming from farm right up
through the value CH so to deal with
that complexity is going to be a
challenge then you get measurement of
R&D investment all those other things
and the bottom line is total Farm
productivity or or profitability it's
the key area of big decisions now at the
moment with big data we are making no in
rides into that area with big decisions
we can probably transform that with
about a 5 or 10% Improvement that's the
type of quantum we can see in
agriculture and value chain efficiency
is just a start to give you an idea
what's already out there this is the
Irish system so the Irish and you think
the Irish are a little bit backwards and
apologies for those people Irish in the
room but they have a lovely piece of
legislation that saids if you breed
cattle in Ireland you have to be part of
that system it's great wouldn't that be
great piece of legislation to putr but
it means every animal in irland is fully
genotyped every animal all the
transactions right the way through its
lifetime are made when it goes to the
avire every piece of information is
actually captured it in the avire all of
that information fed back into a
National Database and that's all made
will back up into decision making around
genetics and completely integrated right
the way through the system you have to
be part of that now the really good
thing is the Irish tapped into the
European Agriculture Commission and they
got something like $70 million to
install and we don't have the luxury
doing that type of area so that's our
job New Zealand again system with New
Zealand that's about $187 million
today now we're talking about in nla
about putting a system that's going to
cost us $2 to $3 million we're not even
in the right ballpark when it comes to
these type of decision making so the
lesson learned from others about talking
thing and we've got a review out at the
moment it's about getting everybody in
the same room and think about where the
wind situations actually are so looking
for people to make decisions and
outcomes and the real key about
integration across the live stock chain
is that you've got to create the win-win
based on aggregation and aggregation to
leads to decisions at the moment Mick
might talk about later on about Open
Access platforms around data well the
real people are asking livestock is open
access around the algorithms that
involve the decision making because at
the moment there is no confidence in a
lot of those algorithms that involved
the decision Mak so we've got to get to
that M no one really knows what big data
is everything everybody thinks is going
to be important uh everybody's applying
a consistent approach and principles to
address that there's Democratic data is
the delivery through public available
apis and everything like that you talk
to everybody everybody thinks yes I'm
involved in Big Data you talk to
everybody about how to using big data on
collecting it collecting big data is not
using big data everybody wants to be
part of it and everybody thinks that
because they've got data they've got
value in big data and people have yet to
work out the only value in data is when
you aggregate that data to make a
decision and we have got to face a real
cultural change in in agriculture about
moving away from IP protectionism to an
open- Source platform that allows big
decisions to be made across agriculture
at the moment we're moving the other way
down other way
around information about genuine value
creating genuine value in the supply
chain or the value chain is a real
critical thing you can make decisions
you can give advice on those type of
things but unless they lead to tangible
value there be no impact on agriculture
as I said before data by itself is not
valuable and people are putting all of
these restrictions around data because
they think they own the data the real
key is to only algorithms that aggregate
the data that's where the real
information is going to be collected and
actually making the public Source most
going and people think that providing
data entitles them more value so I've
listened and we worked with people
recently that said I'm giving you this
data and in in return for this data I
expect
this now in many cases you can't
actually predict what you're going to
give them so how can you actually give
uh take their data without actually
understanding what you're going to give
them back and that's going to be the
learning experience to work over in the
next couple years and then industry own
data I mean as an RDC about 3 months ago
we blindly went into the belief that we
should set up a single National Database
set up all these algorithms do all these
wonderful things control a lot right a
lot of consultations power
is firstly helping set the standards and
secondly helping set the framework about
how you create the algorithms to make
decisions it's not our role to pull the
data together our role is to coordinate
and facilitate the opportunity to do
that so my challenge for the industries
are data is increasingly more complex
it's complicated and volumetric and if
you think farmers are struggling with
day to-day decision making they are
they're struggling with draft decisions
they're struggling with all these things
and suddenly we're going to put this
huge pressure on them to cope with the
information that's coming back to them
and I have already started to see some
of the producers struggling and
particularly in the sea stock industry
struggle with that transition from
visual to information driven decisions
and that is creating culture Big Data
must generate capacity to drive big
decisions so I hope everybody walks out
the room we're thinking about big
decisions rather than big data and the
key barriers engaging everybody along
the value chain and listening what Phil
said earlier about changing the value
chain that horizontal platform of
information transfer is yet to be
discussed because we haven't yet had the
real conversation about agriculture
about integrating livestock with
pastures and cropping and soils
everybody's wor walking in their own
silos and that big decision about
integration has yet to come thanks very
much